ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนปีคะนัก
เรียนไม่ลบเสียงดุดุๆจังเลยพูดอะไรค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ดีไหมคะเสียดายค่ะเอา a.m. เธอค่ะเสียงจะ
ได้ดังๆนะคะอะไรก็ได้ค่ะให้นักเรียนเปิด
ให้นักเรียนตื่นนักเรียนชายอันนี้หู
หูในต้องเปิดหูฟังนะคะกูใหญ่ๆค่ะวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูหญิงวันที่ 3
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
4 มิถุนายน
ปี 2 พ.ศต.ยคะอีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะแต่แล้วเวลากี่โมงคะครูหญิงตอน
นี้เวลา 4 โมง
16 นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไมครูเห็นหน้าผู้หญิง
นักเรียน
ง่วงนอนทุกทีผู้หญิงก็เหมือนกันค่ะกูเอง
อ้าวหน้าครูหญิงเหมือนอ่ะนี้หรือเปล่าคะ
ครูเอ๋อะไรคะอันนี้ไงอันนี้เป็นเตียงนอน
หน้าผู้หญิงไม่ได้เหมือนจริงนอนนะคะ
เหมือนหมอเนี่ยอ่ะ
ข้อ
เท็จลงไปนอน
ไม่ใช่หรอความสุขเองก็จะบอกเหมือนกันครู
เห็นครูหญิงคุยเลยง่วงนอนผู้หญิงตาโตๆได้
อนิตาครูหญิงเล็กๆคุยทำตาตัวโตๆอันนี้
4โมงไงคะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงเนี่ยทุกวันทุกวัน
15:00 น
หรือว่า 16:00 นแล้ว
ง่วงนอนง่วงดอน
8 คูณเอมบอกผู้หญิงมามาทำงานสายเรานะผู้
หญิงก็บอก
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าไม่ต้องรีบทำงานค่ะวันนี้
เหมียวอะไรผู้หญิงวันนี้มีจ่ายคู่หญิง -
ค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงมีคำถามมาถามกูอีก
แล้วหรอคะหาเรา
ถ้าเราก็นักเรียนถามอีกแล้วหรอ
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
แต่ว่าไม่ยากมากมายอ่ะมาค่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ย
อันนี้
Condominium ครูเอ๋นะคะค่ะ Condominium
ครูเอที่ครูเอกใส่ค่ะอันนี้ครู a
เวลาครูออกจากบ้านผู้หญิงผู้หญิงว่าแล้ว
เหมือนอยู่ในกล่องอ่ะ
อันนี้ครูเอ๋
วันวานยากแล้วถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยวาดให้
ครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้เอา iPad มานะคะผู้หญิงใช้
เมาส์ใช้เมาส์นะคะวาดรูปผู้หญิง - ก่อน
ค่ะลบลบครูเอ๋ดูแล้วเฮ้ยครูเอ๋อยู่ที่ไหน
โอเคอ่ะ
อยู่คอนโดนะคะคอนโดก็โอเคคล้ายๆกันแหละ
ที่กูหญิงว่า
แต่ว่าก็จะมีชั้น
คอนโดที่คุณเอ๋อยู่เนี่ยมีหนึ่ง
เหยียบฉันน่ะค่ะ
[เพลง]
3-4
ค่า
7  8  8 ชั้นค่ะคุณหญิงครูเอ๋อยู่ชั้น
ไหนคะฉันที่ 5 ค่ะแต่ที่ครูเอ๋อยู่เขามี
ตรงระเบียงตรงเนี้ยระเบียง
ปลูกต้นไม้ได้นี่ไง
เมตรต้นไม้ก็นะโอเคเป็นคอนโดขึ้นมาหน่อย
จ่ายก็ครูเอ๋เนี่ยจากชั้น 5 แล้วครูเอก็
ลงมาลงมาธนิตอีกาผ่าลงมา
ณ
โรงมาชั้น 1 ค่ะ
แล้วก็เดินเดินเดินๆไปข้างนอกนะคะไปเกิด
ไปเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นก็ได้ค่ะ
มีถนน
สาย
เอกก็ไปเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นซื้อกาแฟและกับนี้
ไม่มีเงินอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะมีเงินนะคะพี่เอ๋
มีเงิน 100 บาทค่ะนี่ 100 บาทแล้วก็ซื้อ
กาแฟนี่อาจจะเป็นลาเต้นากาแฟลาเต้เท่า
ไหร่อ่ะ
40 บาทแล้วกัน
ครูเองไม่รู้นะผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้ฉันไม่คิด
อีก 40 บาทนะโอเคก็ไปซื้อกาแฟว่า
ง่วงนอน
กาแฟก็ไม่กินนมก็ไม่กินนะในรัฐเอ๊ะ
แล้วครูเอกก็เดินกลับคอนโดค่ะเดินกลับ
คอนโดแล้วก็ขึ้นคอนโด
เหตุเดิมเดินกลับคอนโดแล้วก็ขึ้นคอนโด
แล้วก็ถึงห้องครูเอ๋ที่ชั้น 5
กดและก็มีวิ่งมาเชิญข้างโอเคเข้าห้องปิด
ห้องใช่เพราะสิ่งห้องเครปว่างกาแฟวางกาแฟ
ก่อน
วางกาแฟ
ช่วยกันอุ้ยสนอะไรตบกันขวดค่ะน่ะ
มาถึงห้องวางกาแฟแล้วอ่าแล้ววางกาแฟถึง
ห้องปุ๊บครูเอ๋ทำอะไรเป็นอย่างแรกเลยถึง
ห้องเนี่ยอ่าอย่างแรกเหรอคะเพราะวานกาแฟ
ปุ๊บมันพร้อมๆกันเนาะล้างมือ
ขอรองเท้า
ล้างมือใช่ไหมทอลายเอาไม่เอาไม่เอาล่ะฮือ
ร้านขาวอ่ะนักเวทย์ร้าน 2 อย่างเลยใช่ 1
2  3  4  5 อันนี้เท้านะคะครูเอ๋ล้าง
เท้าด้วยร้านค้าวล้างมือ
ล้างเดี๋ยวเขาผู้หญิงเคลียร์ก่อนนะคะมัน
จะต้องล้างนะให้ผู้หญิงล้างมือแต่ไม่ได้
ล้างเมื่อเช้าไม่ได้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงต้อง
ล้างเท้าด้วย
คุยขี้บ่นนี้แล้วใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอันนี้มือ
อันนี้เท้านะครับครูเอ๋เนี่ยล้างเท้าค่ะ
ร้านเช้า
แล้วก็ล้างมือ
ใช่ล้างมือล้างเท้า
ค่ะโอเคเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงขอเลื่อนลงมานะคะ
เจี๊ยบลูก
เดี๋ยวพี่เงินใจเย็นๆล้างก่อนเดี๋ยวจด
เร็วๆ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เนี่ยล้างมือล้างมือมี
น้ำมะขามน้ำเนาะล้างมือครูเอ๋คะผู้หญิงมี
คำถามข้อที่ 2 ค่ะค่ะเชิญค่ะ room อาเจ๊
ล้างมือเนี่ยครูเอ๋ใช้อะไรล้างมือยังไม่
ตอบก็ไม่ต้องตอบนะกูเองกูอย่างดีให้เลือก
เลยใช่หลายอย่างโอเคเชิญค่ะได้กันกล้วย
ใช้หลายอย่าง
อ่ะครูเอ๋เนี่ยใช้ครีมคืออะไรโฟมล้างมือ
เหรอโฟมล้างมือทำไมในรูปไหนเขากดโฟมอัน
นี้เป็นโฟมล้างมือค่ะเพื่อใช้โฟมล้างมือ
ใครว่ากูเองล้างมือโดยฉีดสเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์
หรืออ่าหมดและมี 2  Choice
คุยมี 3  Choice
อ่ะผู้หญิงอยากรู้ว่าครูเอ๋กลับถึงบ้าน
แล้วผู้เหล้างมือยังไงอ่ออ๋อเอ่อ
ผู้หญิงค่ะคุยล้างมือน่ะเวลาปิ๊งป่อง
ก็กดแล้วเนี่ยมีสามีเปิดประตูเนี่ยคู๋
เนี่ยแอลกอฮอล์ล้างมือก่อนกรองหัวฉีด
สเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์ก่อนพอก่อนแล้วก็กด
ติ๊งต๊อง
แล้วก็สามีมาเปิดประตู
ชายคู่เอก็ไปห้องน้ำ
ใช้โฟมล้างมือ
ครั้งที่ 2 แล้วครั้งที่ 3 อ่ะบางทีไม่
ใช้โฟมบางทีใช้ซันไลต์ที่ล้างจานค่ะล้าง
มือ
นะคะใช่อันนี้ดีมากใช้มีทางถ้าไม่ไปห้อง
น้ำก็ซันไลต์ก่อนอ๋อ
เพราะว่าเปิดประตูปั๊บเจอที่ร้านจานก็
ล้างมือสั้นไหล่ล้างมือเอาครูเอ๋ 3 อีก
ประมาณ 2 แล้วกันเนาะชายบางทีโฟมบางที
ซันไลต์ให้แต่ว่าอย่างแรกนะคือตัว S ฉีดส
เปรย์แอลกอฮอล์ล้างมือสร้อยค่ะ
เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยแค่ใช้ในโรงโฟมล้าง
มือล้างมือเท่านั้นหรอ
เวลาคุยอิ๋งเดินๆมาถึงคอนโด
ก่อนนี้กูหญิงจะเปิดประตูคุยก็
แอลกอฮอล์ก่อนนี่แล้วค่อยจับประตูไม่ๆคุย
ครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงต้องมีกุญแจไข
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องฉีดก่อนแล้วก็หยิบกุญแจ
ไม่ผู้หญิงไม่รู้อันนี้เราจะล้างทุกอย่าง
ในบ้านไม่ได้เราล้างมือแล้วค่อยหยิบแล้ว
ถูกล้างมือไงกว่าอ่าเดี๋ยวๆผู้หญิงไป
เซเว่นใช่ไหมมือผู้หญิงและจับเงินเงิน
เนี่ยสกปรกนะมีแต่เบียร์ไม่ไวรัสงั้นเวลา
กูหญิงจะหยิบกุญแจน่ะผู้หญิงต้องมี
แอลกอฮอล์เสร็จแล้วก็หยิบกุญแจ
เพราะว่าคอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงเนี่ยตรง
ตรงทางเข้าอันนี้เป็น Condominium นะคะ
นักเรียนข่า Condominium ผิงว่าไม่สวยเลย
นะคะแล้วก็ชั้น 1 นะคะกูเอ๋ตรงทางเข้า
เนี่ยมันจะมีเป็นเครื่องอันเนี้ย
เครื่องแล้วก็
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น 36
ตัวจะให้ 36 องศาเซลเซียสแล้วก็ต้องนี้
มันก็จะมีที่เหมือนกับที่รองผู้หญิงก็เอา
มือเข้าไปแล้วมันก็จะบอกก็
36 ตัวร้อนคะแล้วก็
สเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์
อ่อนแล้วพิมพ์ก็ได้ก่อนใช่ไหมทรายใจฟรี
คอนโดคู่่ก็มีแต่ว่า
ไม่ไปนะมันอ๋อออกของผู้หญิงมันเป็น
เซนเซอร์ครูเอ๋ค่ะเซ็นเซอร์เซ็นเซอร์ไม่
ทำงานตอบเขากูใหญ่โอ้โหน้ำสเปรย์
แอลกอฮอล์เยอะมากกูอะไรต้องฉีดเอง
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะที่บ้านครูหญิงก็มีสเปรย์
แอลกอฮอล์เยอะ
มั้ยตัวเองก็ได้เนอะจิตเอง
ที่โต๊ะก็มี
แต่นี่ไม่ใช่ชอบนะคะไม่หอมว่าแล้วก็ลัง
เลยบ่อ้าว
ล้างมือหรอก็ผู้หญิงรู้ว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ล้างมือปล่อยบ่อยๆค่ะคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าครู
เอ๋น่ะเวลาพูดเอ๋มีกระเป๋าเนี่ยมีสเปรย์
แอลกอฮอล์เหลวก็จะฉีด
ล้างมือข้าง
กระเป๋าด้วยนะมีกระเป๋า
ไม่เห็นมันกระจายนะ xxx ไม่ดีใช่ไหม
เวลางมือพอแล้วฉีดมือพอแล้วนะคะแต่ว่าเรา
เนี่ยก็ยังล้างอย่างอื่นอีกนะคะครูเอ๋เรา
ไม่ได้ล้างแค่มือ
ร้านอะไรอีกนี่ไงเพราะว่าครูเอ๋บอกแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ถึงบ้านล้างมือหลานเท้าและพระเอกก็
ล้างหน้าด้วยชายใช่
ครูเอ๋ล้างหน้าเนี่ยนะคะ 1 วัน
1 วันนะครูเอ๋ล้างหน้ากี่ครั้งมีถึงวัน
ไหนกูเอ๋ล้างหน้ากี่ครั้งประมาณเดี๋ยวนะ
คะประมาณ 2-3 ครั้ง
2-3 ครั้ง 1 วันค่ะแต่ว่าถ้ามีสบู่หรือ
มีโฟมแบบเนี้ยก็ประมาณ 1 ครั้ง
นี่แต่ว่าถ้าอยู่ที่บ้านแล้วก็ง่วงนอนก็
ไปล้างหน้าแบบนี้ใช่ไหมให้กูเองใช่ลูกคู่
เอ๋คะบาทรอนก็หมุดหมดสิคะ Lipstick
Mascara
ดีไหม
เห็นไหมคะบัตรคอนที่ไหน
ขอลาแค่น้ำเปล่าใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋น้ำเปล่า
แล้วถ้าครูเอ๋ล้างหน้าที่มีกูเห็นใช้โฟม
ล้างหน้าไหมคะแต่ตอนนี้มั้ยไม่ใช้ค่ะอัน
นี้มีอะไรก็มีโฟมแล้วก็ฟองน้ำใช่ไหม
taizai อันนี้น่าจะไม่ใช่แค่ล้างอย่าง
เดียวนะน่าจะบีบโฟมลงฟองน้ำแล้วก็ขัด
ใช่แต่ครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่มีประชรไม่มี
มาสคาร่าก็ก็ไม่ต้องใช้ไม่มีอะไร
ให้ช่วยธรรมชาตินะคะสวยธรรมชาติ
ซูมช่วยให้สวยเหมือนกัน
หรือว่าตัวเอใช้อันนี้ไหมคะว่าหนึ่งเมื่อ
ก่อนว่าก่อนน้อเมื่อก่อนคุยใช้คลีนซิ่ง
หรอคนไทยก็เลขคลีนซิ่งหรอครีมล้างหน้าจะ
มีทีมกับน้ำมัน
นะคะผู้หญิงไม่มีน้ำมันอันนี้เป็นโฟมคู๋
เมย์นะเว้ยจะไม่ได้ใช้อ๋อ
โป้เกย์กี่ถ้ากูไอ้ไปออฟฟิศมีผู้หญิงมี
เมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋ไปออฟฟิศราคาก็จะต้อง
มีอะไรหน่อยมี Lotion โลชั่นยังมีรสสั้น
มีโลชั่นแล้วก็
ทาแป้ง
ทาแป้งก็กลับบ้านก็จะต้องมีสำลีนะคะแล้ว
ก็มีมีอันเนี้ยเนี่ยข้างบนเนี่ยเป็นน้ำ
มันข้างล่างเนี่ยเป็นน้ำแล้วก็ต้องเขย่า
เขย่าละปากเนาะทีมากนะคะคู๋ไม่แพงแล้วก็
เวลาเช็ดเนี่ยไม่แสบตาตาอันนี้ดีที่สุด
ผู้เองพวกเราที่นี่ผู้หญิงให้คุยลองไม่
ค่ะครูหญิงมีอีก 1 ขวด
กูเองไม่ซื้อ
จริงๆกูอันนี้แบบก็คุยมาขายของเหรอคะอัน
นี้ล้างดีมากคิดว่าแบบไม่เจ็บนะฮะแต่
เนี้ยใส่สำลีเขาอาจจะ
บอกรุธ
เดี๋ยวสำลีผู้ใดไม่มีไม่มีเครื่องทำอาหาร
2 ลิตร
ฟรีโทรให้มาขอมีแต่ของฟรีกูเอไปซื้อซื้อ
ของแล้วก็ร้านร้านเนี้ยขอให้ฟรีนะคะ
ขอให้ฟรีมีมากๆผู้หญิงมากเอาไปได้กูๆให้
ได้จริงก็ไม่ค่อยได้ใช้แต่ว่าเวลาที่เรา
เอาใช่กำลังจะบอกเลยค่ะว่าเอาน้ำมันเนี่ย
บีบใส่สำลีเนี่ยเราเช็ดหน้า
เช็ดก่อนนะคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ต้องนวดที่หน้า
นะคะแล้วก็เช็ดออกมี
ท่านวดที่น่าก็อย่างทั้งเลยค่ะเก๋ล้างได้
เลย
ล้าง
นวดที่หน้าก็ดีนะคะเนี่ยเราก็ต้องเราก็
คอยเช็ดหน้าเสร็จก็เอาโฟมล้างหน้าเนี่ย
ล้างหน้าอีก 1 ครั้งหน้าก็จะ
สะอาดชายค่ะไม่มีแบคทีเรีย
ก็จะหน้าสวยเหมือนซูมโอเคสวยแล้วใช่ไหม
อ่ะแต่ว่ายังมีอีกเธอครูเอ๋สิ่งที่เราจะ
ร้านผู้หญิงมีอะไรนะ 1 เช็ตใช่มั้ยครีม
ล้างหน้าระบบ Cream ครีมไม่ใช่สิครีมเช็ด
เครื่องสำอางจ่ายนี้ค่ะนักเรียนเครื่อง
สำอางค์ก็ที่หน้ากูหญิงอ่ะค่ะมีสีแดงๆ
เห็นแก้ม bus  or  on  Less ติกคิวอันนี้
คือเครื่องสำอาง Mini  Lipstick ปาริตา
พืชไม่มีไม่มีค่ะอ๋อ
มาสคาร่าที่ตาไม่มีเรียนเห็นนั้นเห็นขนตา
กูหญิงไว้แล้วคะ
แต่นะเรียนเห็นคิ้วเพราะผู้หญิงเนี่ยมี
มาสคาร่าปัดคิ้วเป็นเครื่องสำอางต้องเช็ด
ออกก่อน
ไม่มีเลย
ผู้หญิงต้องมีอะค่ะจะเช็ดนะใช้ครีมเช็ด
เครื่องสำอางเช็ดมาหา
แล้วก็ลามเสร็จแล้วก็อาจจะมีโฟมอีกหนึ่ง
ครั้งนะคะไทยค่ะล้างหน้า
สายแต่ล้างอันต่อไปเนี่ยครูเอ๋โชคมาก
หลังห้องน้ำหรอคะแต่กูไม่มีค่ะคุณลืมค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
ไว้ช่างหลังห้องน้ำผู้หญิงพูดไปจริงอ่ะกู
เองว่าเอ๋ชอบมากล้างจานค่ะ
ขอโทษค่ะไม่ชอบ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบร้านจานเอาจริงๆนะครูเหมไม่
ชอบล้างจาน
ไม่ชอบเลย
แดกครูเอ๋ต้องล้างจานน้ำ
งั้นเอกก็ต้องใช้เครื่องล้างจานดีไหมคะ
ไม่ชอบมากกว่าเอ้าทำไมมีเครื่องล้างจาน
ผู้เอกก็ไม่ต้องล้างจานเอง
ก็ต้องล้างแล้วก็ใส่เครื่องล้างจานแล้วก็
ล้านเป็นล้าน 2 ครั้งต่อไปเอาใช่ไหมล้าง
มือใช้มือนดีเจลล้างมือได้ให้อาหารใส่ไม่
ชอบล้างฆ่าใช่ค่ะแซกผู้หญิงชอบนะ
คุยไม่ชอบเลยแต่ว่าเวลาเห็นจาแล้วแบบก็
ต้องร้านถ่ายชายๆถ้าไม่ล้าง 1 วันสองวัน
เนี่ยมีกลิ่นห้องมีกลิ่นนะคะแล้วถ้ากิน
ข้าวด้วยกันแล้วทุกคนไม่ล้างจานให้ครูเอ๋
ละ 1 วันสองวันสามวันสี่วันคุย
กะโหลดไม่เป็นไรค่ะถ้ากินข้าวกับครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงล้างให้ชอบล้างจานชอบคนเดียวค่ะ
คู๋ออกไปออกไปกูก็ออกไปผู้หญิงล้างคน
เดียวโอเคผู้หญิงก็กินอะไรก็เอ๋ซื้อให้
ซื้อให้ Apple
โอเคแฮปปี้เล่น rov ลีโอเคเห็นเพลงแพงๆนะ
คะได้แต่คุยอีกล้างจานนะโอเค
ครูเอ๋คะแล้วเวลาที่เราล้างจานเราใช้อะไร
ล้างจานล้างจานเราต้องมีฟองน้ำโทรครูเมย์
มีฟองน้ำอ้าว
กูอยู่บ้านกับสามีเพจต้องล้างเนาะไม่ได้
อยู่กับครูหญิง
kuai ให้สามีช่วยล้างเออนี่ไงอะไรหรอมี
ฟองน้ำแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋น้ำยาล้าง
จาน
ครูเอ๋ใช้น้ำยาล้างจานล้างมือด้วยบาง
ครั้งแล้วก็ต้องมีพากย์ผู้หญิงอันนี้ไม
อ่ะมีถึงวันนี้เป็นผ้าเหรอเนี่ยเป็นผ้า
นัดสำหรับอ่ะเช็ดหน้า
ทีเด็ดจานเหรอคะบางทีมีผ้าเช็ดจานแต่บาง
ทีเช็ดที่ที่ล้างจานนะคะอ๋ออ๋อเช็ดที่
อ่างล้างนานใช่ไหมคะพี่อ่าเนี่ย
นะมีอะไรผู้หญิงเสร็จแล้วผู้หญิงต้อง
ปากกาและใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงโดนด่าไปๆค่ะครูเอ๋
คะเรื่องน้ำเนี่ยค่ะให้ด่าคะน่าจะรู้นะคะ
เก๋ไม่ไหมคะผู้หญิงร้าย
น้ำเต็มไปหมดเลยค่ะเนี่ยตรงเนี้ยถ้ามีน้ำ
มีน้ำใช่มันจะ
เช็คเขาต้องมีพาดเช็ดด้วยใช่ไหมคะก็ดีมา
อ๋อโอเคค่ะไม่เป็นไรอ่ะครูเอ๋ชอบล้างชอบ
หลังถักไหมคะอันนี้กูเอชอบนะคะถ้าชอบ
ไม่ชอบล้างจานแบบชอบจะล้างผักได้ทำไมอ่ะ
เหมือนกันนะล้านไม่เหมือนกันเองคุยซอด
หลังชาติล้างผักแล้วไสวใจ
สะอาดสะอาดค่ะคุณเอ๋
เวลาครูเอ๋ล้างถาดเนี่ยคุยล้างผักแบบนี้
ใช่ไหมคะเอาผัดเนี่ยใส่ลงไปในซิงค์ร้าน
จานแล้วก็หยิบขึ้นมาล้างทีละชิ้นที่ทีละ
รูปคู่ A มีกะละมังด้วยก็เก่งอะไรจะถาม
ว่ารู้ว่าครูเอ๋ใช้กับเรามั้งอันนี้ร้าน
กะละมังอันนี้มีรู้เออเออบางคนใช้กะละมัง
มีรูที่บ้านครูหญิงมีนะกะละมังมีรูเนี่ย
กูเอกเป็นแบบนี้วาดได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะหน้าไม่
ตรงไหนว่าน่ะกูเอกจะเป็นกะละมังแบบนี้นะ
คะตัวเองแล้วเดี๋ยวๆ
เอาโอเคกับอาจเป็นกะละมังแล้วก็ข้างในมี
เป็นแบบนี้อ่ะอ่าอันนี้มีรู้
มีรู้
แล้วก็ผักจะอยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็น้ำก็จะอยู่
ที่นี่
แล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็ข้างบนด้วยคือเอา 2
อย่างรวมกันแล้วก็ล้างทีละลูกค่ะเอ้าเอ้า
แล้วก็เปิดน้ำล้างล้างล้างอาทิครูเอชอบ
ใช่ไหมแต่ล้างผัดเราไม่ต้องใช้อะไรใช่ไหม
คะเราใช้แค่น้ำอย่างเดียวไม่
คุยไซส์อะไรอีกล่ะไม่ใช้น้ำยาล้างจานล้าง
ผ่านตัวซะ
ผู้หญิงล้างเสร็จแล้วคุณต้องใช้ Baking
Soda
ขอคุยที่บ้านผู้หญิงมีเยอะเลย Baking
Soda เนี่ยผู้หญิงวิ่งไปเอากับนักเรียน
ค่ะเรียนรู้จักใช่ไหมเด็กกิ้งโซดาของนัก
เรียนอีกอ่ะให้นักเรียนบอกว่าเอ๊ะ Baking
Soda ภาษาอะไรภาษาอังกฤษ
ของเรากี่ถ้าหลังนะคะนักเรียนล้างผัก
เนี่ยต้องดูว่าผักอะไรบางคนบางคนใช้อ่ะ
Baking  Soda บางคนใช้เกลือ
เกลือเค็มเค็มๆใช่บางคนก็ใช้น้ำส้มสายชู
งูเปรี้ยวอ่ะนะใช่ๆมันจะสะอาดมากก็
ขอก็ดีใช่ไหมเอ๋เออ่ก็ใช้ Baking  Soda
นิดหน่อยค่ะส่งค่ะโอเคอ่ะมีอีกค่ะผู้เห
ล้างอะไรคะหลายรสค่ะไม่ล้างค่ะเหมือนกัน
คู่หญิงก็ไม่มีรถแต่ว่านิร้านเองใช่ไหมก็
คือเราเป็นคนแล้วก็ล้างเองค่ะแต่มันก็จะ
มีล้างรถแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะนะล้างแบบไหนคะอ้อ
ขับรถเข้าไปแล้วก็จะมีเครื่องล้างรถคู่
เอกเคยเข้านะแบบเนี้ยสนุกไหมคู๋ไม่ชอบ
แล้วผู้หญิงชอบ
ตัวเอกเคยดูหนังแล้วกลัวอ๋ออ๋อแต่ว่าถ้า
เราล้างรถเองนะคะมันก็จะต้องใช้ฟองน้ำ
เหมือนกันเนาะฟองน้ำล้างรถยฟอลล์น้ำล้าง
รถไปค่ะแล้วก็ต้องมีอันนี้
ฝักบัวเหรอคะถ่ายค่ะเป็นสายฉีดน้ำเนาะ
อาสายฉีดน้ำสายฉีดน้ำดีถังน้ำสถานมีสีฟ้า
เหมือนกันเนี่ยนะทางน้ำแล้วก็มีน้ำยา
หลั่งรถจ่ายตีใส่ถังน้ำแล้วก็ล้างรถ
ซันไลต์ได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะเพราะว่ารถรถรถ
มีสีไงเดี๋ยวสีไม่สวยต้อง
เป็นนั่งคิดๆน้ำยางรถ
สองคนไม่ขับรถนะคะจ่ายอย่าคิดว่าเป็นน้ำ
ยาล้างรถดีกว่าค่ะ
อ่ะจะได้อันนึงนะแค่นั้นนะคะให้ต่อไปอัน
นี้เขาทำอะไรครับครูเอ๋สระผมค่ะเสื้อใน
สระผมครูเอ๋เนี่ยสระผมทุกวันไหมคะตอนนี้
ทุกวัน
แล้วก็อะไรอะไรถ้าไปข้างนอกกลับมาล้างมือ
รหัสร้านค้าเมื่อเช้า
ล้างหน้า
สระผมอ๋อถ้ากู a ไปข้างนอกทุกวันก็ล้าง
มือสระผมหลานเท้าทุกวันชาย
เราใช้อะไรสระผมคะครูเอ๋
ยาสระผงฟูเอใช้อันนี้ไหมครีมนวดไม่ข่าย
เออเหมือนกันผู้หญิงก็ไม่ใช้คิดไม่อายใช้
แล้วผมไว้บ้างอ๋อ
ถ้าไม่ใส่ผมกูเอ็นน่ะอยู่แล้วไม่ใช้
แล้วอีกลูกหนึ่งนี้เขาทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋ซัก
ผ้าค่ะโอเคคะไม่มีคำถามค่ะอะไรคะ
2022  2022 เนี่ยมีคนใช้มือ
ข้าวไหมคะอ่ะก็มีค่าซักเสื้อแบบนี้นะใช่
ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋หรอคู๋ก็ซักคุณแม่ครูเอกก็ซะโหแข็ง
แรงนะไม่แข็งแรงหรอกแต่ชอบ
ไม่เคยยิ่งเองแหละ
ใช่กูเอกรอดทุกวันก็ซักผ้าแบบนี้เก๋มี
กะละมังซักผ้ามีค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเมื่อก่อนนะเวลาคุยเด็กๆต้องมี
กะละมัง 1  2 เยอะจำได้ไหมแล้วจะบอกเอก
คิดว่ากูไม่รู้เหรอคะผู้หญิงกะละมัง
กะละมังกะละมังกะละมัง
นักเรียนอันนี้อันนี้ในรูปเนี่ยนะกะละมัง
เล็กนะคะแต่ว่าจะมีกาละมังใหญ่ใหญ่กับ
เนี้ยที่สูงแบบนี้ค่ะนักเรียนสูงประมาณ
เนี๊ยประมาณ 1 กุ้ย
1 ฟุตนกผู้หญิงเนาะ We  are  you  a นี้
ก็ไม่เล่นอันนี้ก็ไม่ได้เท่าไหร่ใช่อัน
นี้สู้ Food เนี่ยนะคะจะมี
2-3 กะละมังสำหรับซักผ้า
ชายค่ะเพราะว่ามีเวลาไหมคะก็วัดจ่ายกับ
อ่ะอันเนี้ยคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
ก็เอ๋เนาะอะพี่สาวก่อนไอ้เอ๋
แม่มีพี่สาวคนนี้ค่ะให้เอ๋ซักมีกะละมัง
กะละมังที่ 1 กะละมังที่สองถ้าเรามางที่ 3
กะละมังเล็กๆอีกหนึ่ง
ของโอ้ไม่รู้กี่กะละมั้งนี่ค่ะกาละมัง
เยอะมาก
จะมีกาละมัง
เรือ
กะละมัง
กระโปรง
น่ารักเต็มที่เหมือนกันนะให้แยกกัน
อันนี้กะละมังใส่น้ำใช่ไหมคะมีกาละมังถุง
เท้า
ถุงเท้าด้วยมีกะละมังชุดชั้นใน
ค่ะหน้ามีการนังค่าเช็ดหน้าผ้าเช็ดหน้า
แบบลองให้เราก็เสร็จหน้าเหนื่อยไหม
เหนื่อยมากค่ะแต่ก็โอเคนะโอเคทำบ่อยๆ
โอเคตอนแรกๆแบบ
จ่ายค่ะคู๋ก่อนจะจบเวลาที่เราซักผ้านะคะ
ไม่ว่าจะซักมือหรือซักเครื่องเราใช้อะไร
คะ
ผู้หญิงใช้เครื่องหรือมือคะมีใช้เครื่อง
ค่ะถ้าเป็นเสื้อหนังใส่เครื่อง
ถ้าเป็นก็ใช้เสื้อใช้สีชุดชั้นใน
อยู่ในมือ
ว่าอพาร์ทเม้นท์ไหมค่ะคอนโดมิเนียมไม่ให้
นะคะของครูเอ๋ทั้งหมดมือโถแล้วครูเอ๋
เนี่ยเวลาซักผ้าใช้ผงซักฟอกหรือว่าใช้น้ำ
ยาซักผ้าคะใช้น้ำยาซักผ้าค่ะ
แหวนการเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็ใช้น้ำยาซักผ้าแล้ว
คู่หญิงมีน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มไหมคะ
มีค่ะนีค่ะน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มครูหญิงใช้ไหม
คะไม่ใช้ค่ะครูเอ๋ใช้ไหมคะไม่ใช้ค่ะไม่
ชอบชายผู้หญิงชอบกลิ่นของน้ำยาซักผ้าแล้ว
โอเคหอมนะคะนาผอ.วันนี้นักเรียน
น้ำยาปรับผ้านมได้ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้
จักล้างมือ
ไปล้างหน้า
ร้านค้าวค่ะสระผมตาล้างจาน
ซักผ้าล้างผักล้างผักสมัยร้านแครอทนะคะ
แต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วหรอเดี๋ยวเรา
ไปเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย